Good afternoon, Ayra. Good afternoon, Lee.
Yes, good afternoon.
Hey, Sage, hey, Ayra, how you both doing?
Hey there, I'm good. How about you?
Doing good.
Yeah, how about you?
I'm doing well.
Rocking and rolling.
Almost Friday.
Yeah.
Meeting after meeting after meeting after meeting.
Daily routine.
Yeah.
I was like, don't you pick and break them between your meetings? I was like, oh, you think I get to book all my meetings? As though I have any, they take place. How are we doing here? How are we doing with Jocelyn and team?
Just.
Right.
Yeah, we are doing good with Jocelyn.
Okay.
Yeah, see, doing good.
Well...
Cool. All right, well, I'm here with a fly on the wall. I know there's a number of things moving, and I heard about one of the non-renewals, so I wanted to make sure that I could capture any sentiment that might be that might be offered, and...
Um...
and elevate it as needed. So that's all.
Sure.
Gotcha. Okay, thank you. I'll drop an email to Jocelyn or helping her to remind her of this meeting. Hold on.
She's joining in a bit. She said that she's going to join. There you go.
I am so sorry. I was in the middle of doing expense reports and didn't even see the pop up. So that's how dedicated I am. I was just laser focused, wanting to make sure people get paid.
If.
Thank you for waving.
No problem.
And good afternoon, Jocelyn.
Afternoon.
The.
We got Lee here. Why do we have Lee?
Because I haven't seen you in a while.
What's going on?
Yeah.
I haven't seen you in two or three months and I was like, I need to jump out and say hello. You're still here.
I got.
I got nervous.
When were we in Jersey?
What's that? I was gonna say, that's why I'm that's why I'm checking in. You're gonna be coming to build it in a couple months, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, we were just...
I know you registered. I just, I think you registered at the last event, and I wanted to make sure nothing.
We did.
We have registered myself, Eric, and I believe Eric registered Lisa, his wife, and Tim, but unfortunately nobody could find the registration for Lisa or Tim.
Hold on.
Yes, yes.
On our side.
Yeah, so I had no proof. I don't know if Eric did it or not, but he worked it out for Lisa and it's okay because Tim is going to a different event, even though I wanted him really at this event.
Give me space.
Is he going to like teenage him?
I don't know, he's going to Saratoga.
Mhm.
Big.
For something, I...
Even in Saratoga.
That's what I said. I'm like, this is more.
Whatever. He can have his little boys.
Oh.
Conference ever.
We'll be glad to have you and Eric there.
Yeah, so I think somebody asked me to do a fireside chat, so I was very excited about that.
Well, that's great.
Um, you know, I like talking and getting in front of people, so I should have been in Atul.
I think.
I mean, there's time.
We're above ground. There's always time.
Um...
Yeah, so now we'll be going in August and I understand.
Eric made me, yeah, we registered the hotel for longer because he's like, we have to go to the party. I was like, you guys and your parties, man, I can't, I can't party like that. I can't do it. You know?
Yeah, you do.
I don't know if you saw me there, but I also cannot party like that. But I can watch other people party like that.
Lee, I can't be walking around Manhattan downtown in August in full. Now I'm gonna dress up again. And it just, I'm like, what am I gonna get? I gotta get some beaded dress and some pearls. I don't know, but I'm like, I'm gonna.
Great Gatsby. I know, I know.
I, I got it.
Be there, just, yeah.
I've got to find a zutsu and a fedora. And I used to have both of these things, and I don't anymore. Because, you know, I was...
Yeah, I used to have stuff too, Lee, you know, when I went out and did things like that, and now I just, you know, I got garden gloves and shears and like...
Yeah.
I mean, you could try, you could try wearing those and bringing it.
Anyway.
Yeah, alright.
We're completely derailing Sage and Ayra. I am so sorry. Well, I'll go on mute and I'll just be environment.
Yes, we are. We are.
This.
It's fine.
Yeah.
No, that's okay.
Shall we start? You can go first, OK.
Okay.
Yes, please.
Okay, all right, I can go first. All right, Jocelyn, so I'll start with the NOC deck presentation. So just give me one second, let me share my screen.
Okay.
Sure.
Okay, I hope.
Look at this. Oh, fancy. Whoa.
Is it looking good?
Looking good, fancy. All right.
Yeah, so this I made using our QBR generator. So in few minutes, it gives me all the data and looking good.
Look at that, confidential and client ready.
Yep.
Love it, OK.
All right, Jocelyn, so this is the monthly business review. So this deck will include the data for the month of May.
And we will talk about the SLA performance. We will talk about the ticket volume, patching compliance, backup compliance, any action plan and to-dos from this meeting.
Is this using AI? I don't know if it got some of the characters right.
Yeah, we generated it using a QBR generator. So I saw that too. So when I go into presentation mode, it changes to that font for some reason. If I change it back, then it goes back to normal. So I asked the team to fix it. Yeah.
Chenier.
Okay.
And okay.
That's when, OK.
That is wild. We got to fix that.
OK.
Yeah.
Total manage ticket volume declined significantly. OK.
Yeah, so this is the ticket volume, Jocelyn. So we received total of 540 tickets last month. So in comparison to April, there is a 39% of volume drop. In April, there were 887 tickets. So when I was looking at the tickets, I saw the reason is that in April, we were getting a lot of.
Right.
temperature alerts specifically for one client. And I remember I saw the engineers reaching out to you in the Teams channel, and I think we made some changes into the threshold. So after that, the count was reduced. But yeah, the increased count was because of those tickets in April.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hey.
And this is the SLA data, Jocelyn. So this is for the response SLA. We are doing good on the SLA side. If I talk about the P1 response SLA, we are standing on 97%, P2 is on 99%, P3 and P4 remained on 100%. So there were four tickets.
in P1 where the response SLA was missed and one ticket on P2 where the response SLA was missed. So this was just by a few seconds and this SLA is response SLA, so the dispatch team, the dispatcher missed to assign the ticket to the engineer within a few minutes. So that is the reason for the SLA miss.
But...
Please improve on that. I want to see 100% across all. Yeah.
And...
Definitely. I have shared some feedback and there are a few things we are doing on our end to make sure.
Sage, I'm joking. I'm joking.
Yeah.
The numbers are good. The numbers are good.
All right, so this is resolution SLA, Jocelyn. Resolution SLA team is doing good. For P1, we are standing on 100%. P2 is 96, P3 is 98%, P4 is again on 100%. So P2, there were three tickets on P2 where the SLA was missed. So on one ticket, I saw the engineer took.
a longer time to resolve the issue. That was the reason. On 2 tickets, the ticket was, the issue was actually resolved, but the engineer did not enter the notes in time. So that is the reason why he missed the SLA. But overall, we are doing good. The numbers are above the target that we have.
So looking good on the SLA, but do you have any questions?
No. Nope.
Thank you.
Okay, so this is the patch compliance data, Jocelyn. So last month I checked the patch report earlier today. So currently we have 16 servers which are showing as fully patched and compliant. There are 42 servers on which we see that patches are approved and they are scheduled to install.
in the next window and 35 are on reboot pending. So they will be rebooted as per the schedule. And there is one which is showing no data, so the team will investigate and fix the agent issue that we are facing.
Do we know which one that is? I think there was one last time as well.
I'm wondering if it's the same client.
Last time.
I'll have to check the report, but last time there was one server which was in install error, Jocelyn, that was the Falvi TS server.
Yeah, that's what I'm concerned about. Okay.
Yeah, but I think we were able to patch it. We were able to fix that issue with fail VTS. Yes.
Okay.
So it's not showing in this month's report. But I'll check the no data when I'll send you the name in the email after the call.
And I checked the last reboot and the uptime of the servers, Jocelyn. So last month all servers were rebooted as per the schedule. So there was no miss on the patching side.
Okay.
Good.
And this is the backup compliance, Jocelyn. So we received total of 103 tickets on the backup board. 97 were for the patch failure and two were quarterly test restores and four weekly reports that the team is sending. And overall success rate was on 99.13%.
and we completed one quarterly test restore and there is one which is scheduled in the coming week.
Good.
But any questions, Jocelyn, on backup?
Nope.
Yeah.
Oh.
So action plan, so the action plan for me, which is the patch remediation, so the patches which are showing approved, they will be installed as per the schedule for all the clients, Jocelyn. But any other thing that you want me to take care of or any feedback for the NOC team?
How many problem tickets do we have open?
Problem tickets currently, Jocelyn, we do not have open anyone. So yeah. So the team is, yeah, team is still looking for the data. So if they see any repeat alert, they will let you know and we'll create the problem ticket for it. But currently there is no ticket. So that's why it's not in the slide.
No, no.
Fantastic.
Okay, good. There you go.
Yeah.
Right, so I think that's all. Sorry, Lee.
No problem.
I said, no problems, huh?
Gotta love that.
Yeah, yeah, there were a few problem tickets, repeat alerts we created and we were able to fix them. So currently things are looking good. But yeah, as soon as we see anything making noise, definitely we will create tickets and we will let you know.
But that's great.
Okay, good.
Right. And apart from this, Jocelyn, just one thing wanted to discuss. I saw your email about the network device maintenance. So I checked with Samir as well. So the device count is not too high. If you need, we can go ahead and we can onboard those network devices for monthly maintenance and monitoring.
For the dado stuff.
For the data stuff, yeah.
at no additional cost.
Yeah, I can talk to Samir. He was telling me, yeah, we can onboard.
Oh, well, that's brilliant.
For the data devices, yeah, for the devices in data.
Send them.
Okay.
All right, so let me talk to, yeah, I mean, that's awesome. So you guys will handle that stuff.
Mhm.
Remind me again, and we can do this separate if you want, but remind me, you're going to set up tickets to your board for anything that's like a switch that's offline, an AP that's offline, and you're going to handle all of that, right?
We'll have to make few changes, yeah, in the workflow and in the alerting that is configured in data networking so that the tickets can land on the NOC board. And yeah, then we can start monitoring and monthly maintenance for those devices which are in data networking.
Okay.
Okay, so that switches and APs.
Yes.
Fantastic! Alright, do it up.
All right, sure.
That's awesome. I'll let my team know and I'll tell them to ignore. I'll shut off the alerting after. All right, so I'll put that on my calendar for next week. Shut off alerting.
To my Support team.
Mhm.
Awesome.
So, just...
Fantastic.
No problem, Jocelyn. So just give me some time. Let me talk to Samir, okay? And let me make the changes required. Once everything is set up, I'll let you know. I'll send you an official email, and then we will move over the monitoring.
Yeah.
Oh, good.
Good, okay. And then I'll go over it with my team. Fantastic.
Yes.
Okay, perfect. So I'll create a to-do for me to work on this network onboarding piece, Jocelyn, and I will let you know once we are ready.
Fantastic. Thank you.
All right, so apart from it, Jocelyn, any feedback for the NOC team? Anything that you think we need to improve or any suggestions?
No, you guys are great. I recommend you often.
Yeah, I saw that email. Thank you. Thank you so much for the recommendation, Jocelyn.
Yeah, no problem.
All right, so I think that's all the data we have, Jocelyn. So our next call will be next month in July. So I'll be showing you the data on the next call. And hopefully by then we'll have the network devices onboarded.
Right on. Perfect.
Yeah, thank you, Jocelyn. Thank you so much for your time.
Thanks. Thanks, Sage. OK.
All right, Ayra, over to you.
Thank you, Sage. All right, cool. Let me share my screen.
Let me know once you see it, Jocelyn.
Yep, not yet.
Should be visible now.
Just came up, yeah.
Okay, thank you. So this is for our Helpdesk team, Jocelyn, for the month of May. Same agenda items, no changes on that one. For check-in, this is for you. How are things at this moment? Are there any feedback? Are there any challenges?
No, I think we, I think the challenge was just utilization and some of the things I was looking at on this side and made the tough decision to cut Dave. But, you know, other than that, Christian's doing really well. He's asking me about tickets, you know, if he can pick them up. He's keeping me informed of things. So.
He's doing a good job.
Okay, thank you. And apologies. A while ago, there was an update. So good thing that all are up and running.
So for the action tracker, thank you, Jocelyn, for filling out the Q1 and PS survey in the monthly CSAT for our guys. Thank you for doing it monthly. You've been very proactive on this one.
Yeah, thank you.
Yep.
Thank you.
Performance analysis slide, same KPIs that we follow.
This is the utilization trend chart, both for Dave and Christian. For a four-week period of May, they both hit the target. They both closed at 87% from May 1 to 29th. I did separate the billable and non-billable.
so we can see the things that they've been working on apart from the meetings, trainings and all. So if we can see here, we can see that there are still the non-billable are quite high. When I checked in with them, they mentioned that there were also
alerts and monitoring tickets that's under non-billable. So that explains the reason why we have non-billable hours. But then for Dave, it shows an upward trend, which is very good. And then for Christian,
Yeah.
It's A downward trend. It's because he was on PTO for four days. So that's just the reason. Any questions for utilization trend?
No.
Okay, cool. This is for ticket closure trend. Both Christian and Dave hit the target. They are above the 80% target. So for Christian, he closed at 97%. Total tickets closed last
month was 76. So that's 97% if we compute it. For Dave, he's very good as well. He was able to close 73 tickets. So what I have observed from these guys, once they have a ticket, they make sure that they close it too.
Yep.
There you go. For Dave, you chose a more stable trend and for Christian is a downward trend. Same issue. It's because of his paid time off.
Customer satisfaction, we have one of each from Dave. This was from Donna. He said that, she said that there was a mistake on the survey, so she sent another one. She said that Dave was great. Her cushion is pretty long. This is from Marine, Flagship Management Services.
Yeah.
I highlighted that secure future tech has always responded in a timely fashion. Wow, that's very cool. And then for the way...
She pays for the work. She's not under contract. She pays whenever she calls in. So the way we bill things, when you look at billable versus non-billable, it really, you can't really tell from that who gets billed and who doesn't, right? Because it really goes by contracts.
Ohh, well...
Mhm.
But she doesn't have a contract and for some reason she doesn't want to sign one, but she calls us all the time and she pays. So, hey, I'm happy if she's happy. That was a tough one. So he pulled me in on that ticket.
Ketan.
And I mean, this is, it was just a crazy issue that the ISP email she was using, they said, we're not doing this anymore, and they pushed them to Yahoo Mail. And then another email platform, and it was just, they couldn't help her get into the account, but the multi-factor,
was going to the email that she couldn't get into. So it was ridiculous. And I was just giving him pointers on what to do, you know, and that she would need to be a part of this because it's her email. We don't manage any of it. We don't know anything about it. So he did a good job with that. It took longer, but.
He did a great job, so.
Yeah, I did remember this one. It was from yesterday, right? Or the other day. It was, yeah, it's the every mail.
Yeah, the other day. Yep.
This is weird.
Well then, hopefully we did make her happy. So that's the goal. Customer service. Perfect. For the way forward, we remain committed, Jocelyn, to provide you with the best service that we can offer. So we want to make sure that if you need help, we're there for you. So just let us know.
And we waited.
Yes.
Yeah.
We're always available. Plus, right here, Dave's last working day would be on June 12th, right? And I did ask him to not tell it to anyone yet. I know that you will be doing that on your end. And also, I haven't included it, but then
Yes.
there, they will be on, we have a scheduled holiday on June 12th, but if you need them, we can disregard that.
Do you need them to talk?
I will, I will need them because I have a lot of my team members out.
Okay, cool. I'll let them know for sure.
So, thank you.
for Team GPS, that's the same and other ITBD by Design products. And we're at the end of this slide. You want to add anything here, Lee?
Do you have any questions?
Well, not about the deck overall. Jocelyn, I know we are or have stopped one of the agreements with Dave.
Yeah.
And I just, I just wanted to, I understand some of the pain points. I know we all agreed on them. I wanted to make sure that, you know, while we're bringing that down, I guess just see, is there any anywhere else in the business where there's value in finding a different skill set?
or somebody else to like swap in and help. Is there any remaining business need? I guess is the way I'll phrase it.
Not right at this second.
And part of the issue I'm facing is...
Right now.
From what I can see, the teams that we have here stateside, some of our lower level team members, and what I mean by that is, you know, newer team members or tier one, tier 2 type guys, they're becoming very lax and very complacent.
Mhm.
With just leaving things.
for Dave and Christian and their utilization has dipped and I've been watching it for the past few months. And I talk to them and go over things and yeah, it's not a good look. So.
We had some other issues with Dave, and after talking to Eric, we decided, I said, you know, it is what it is. Dave was the weaker link. I said, so we got a cut, make a cut. And yeah, we decided, unfortunately, it was Dave. So I need the local team members to kind of step up.
Yeah.
And this is going to give them a little reality slap almost, which...
No.
Pre.
Unfortunately, it has to be done sometimes. They get too complacent.
It's not the professional way to put it, but it's true.
Right, yeah, no, but absolutely here.
No.
Yeah, not at this time. Yep.
Sorry, can you hear me okay?
OK, amazing understood totally. Here's my here's my only request from you is as you're continuing to evaluate those team members who have been failing to step up, if they can, if they continue.
Yeah.
I would love if you'd give us the opportunity to, you know, get you another teamer who's not Dave, who would be handling the things that need to be handled that people are choosing not to handle because they think somebody's there. If you make a decision to go away from anyone you have locally,
Mm-hmm.
That's really what I'm saying. And I know that's not a decision to take lightly. Okay, brilliant. Yeah, because I hear that concern and I think, oh my goodness, you know, if we're in a position to beat on cost for them and be more effective, then I, of course, know that you.
Yeah. Oh, absolutely.
No, absolutely, and I've heard.
Right.
You know, like I said, not an easy decision to make, but if you, when you do, I really appreciate that.
Yeah, absolutely. And honestly, I mean, I would have preferred to keep...
someone who was more cost effective, right? But I also have to keep in mind that some of these guys are in office together every day. They've been here a lot longer.
Yeah.
So I have some work to do to get them back where they're supposed to be. Now, if that plan is, you know, put into place and that doesn't happen, then I'm going to have to make some decisions. And the first thing I would do if I need to hire more bodies would, you know, I'd go to you guys.
It's a struggle sometimes because these guys have to go on site, right? And these guys do go on site. They set up the C's on site, so it's...
Amazing.
Right.
It's that fine balance to keep, but absolutely, I would much prefer to get to a point where, hey, I'm cutting somebody, you know, it's less overhead for me and gives you guys an opportunity to bring somebody else in. So that will be my next move. So we're on the same page.
I think Lee is gone.
Uh, Leaf is talking, you're on mute.
I think, I think his ohh.
No, I'm here. I just I had a bit of a connection for a moment. I should be. I can hear you.
Yeah.
Connection problem.
Yeah, I could hear you, so can you hear me now?
OK.
Yep, yep.
OK, yeah, no, I can hear you for almost everything you said. I can hear perfectly clear, so thank you for sharing. Appreciative of the. You know, keep those that as things you know keep keep chugging in the right direction and.
Yeah.
And yeah, we'll bring it up again when it makes sense.
Okay, thank you.
All right, thank you so much, Lee, for that. How about you, Jocelyn? Anything you want to bring up apart from that?
Thank you.
No, I'm good.
Okay, thank you. Sage, you're still there.
What's that?
Yeah, I'm here.
Okay, are we good? If, okay, perfect. So thank you so much everyone for joining. See you next month. Have a good one. Bye.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're all here.
Okay, thank you. See ya.
Thank you, Jocelyn. Have a good day. Bye bye.
Yeah, alright. Talk soon, everybody. Cheers.
See ya. Bye.